bonsoir Stéphane Marion après donc 8
hausse de taux de suite qu'est-ce qu'il
fondamentalement permet aujourd'hui à la
Banque du Canada de dire on avait dit
une pause conditionnelle bah c'est une
pause puis on respecte notre pause
composition économique est différente de
celle des États-Unis on est une économie
beaucoup plus cyclique
et dans ce sens
il y a ce qui se passe au niveau mondial
qui va mordre au Canada on pense au prix
des denrées en baisse de 30% depuis les
dépasser donc si les commodités
produites au Canada qui plus est c'est
10% d'économie canadienne qui est
dépendante des de l'investissement
résidentiel contrairement à 5% aux
États-Unis donc c'est une économie qui
est plus
axé sur ce qui se passe au niveau
mondial mais aussi plus exposé aux auto
intérêts donc je pense que c'était la
très certainement la bonne décision de
prendre une pause est-ce que il y a
quand même une pression inflationniste
qui demeure présentement surtout dans le
secteur alimentaire comment on peut
contrecarrer cette inflation là
précisément qui touche directement les
gens pour ce qui est des aliments les
énergies là les deux sont corrélés en
passant le prix de l'énergie basse
présentement donc j'ai bon espoir que ça
peut aider au niveau alimentaire mais
faut pas oublier que j'ai deux
billigérants une guerre en Russell
Russie-Ukraine qui est ces deux
producteurs de commodités donc il peut
avoir de certaines surprises il y a peu
qu'on peut faire à ce niveau là pour la
Banque du Canada moi je veux juste dire
que l'inflation sur trois mois elle est
à 3.4% mais si on exclut les hausses de
taux parce que les hausses de tout
Canada sont dans l'indice canadien pas
aux Etats-Unis l'inflation doit être à
deux pour cent donc la décélération est
encore plus importante si on retranche
l'impact des hausses des taux
hypothécaires qui dans l'inflation mais
quand on parle de l'alimentaire
puisqu'on parle de l'énergie
particulièrement est-ce que de revenir à
3% de ramener le taux d'inflation qui
est à 5,9 au Canada à 3% cet été c'est
réaliste moi je pense que c'est encore
réaliste absolument
la question après ça c'est ce qu'on peut
le maintenir à ce niveau-là pour 2024 et
les années subséquentes dans un contexte
de transition énergétique qui s'avère
inflationniste au niveau mondial est-ce
que d'autres hausse de taux d'intérêt
sont possibles est-ce que d'autres
hausse de taux d'intérêt vont arriver en
2023 au Canada
je penche plus pour une baisse que pour
des hausses en 2023 mais encore faut-il
que je confirme un ralentissement au
niveau de l'emploi faut pas oublier
monsieur Filion qu'est-ce qui détermine
la croissance de l'emploi ben c'est la
direction des profits des entreprises
hors depuis deux trimestres on observe
des gens une contraction au niveau des
profits des entreprises au Canada puis
aux États-Unis ont fait du surplace à
partir de maintenant donc historiquement
lorsque les profits sont en baisse on
réduit le cycle d'embauche donc je pense
que c'est la donner les banques
centrales vont être en mode réaction au
cours des prochaines semaines puis vous
l'avez dit c'est le secteur de l'emploi
qui pourrait faire en sorte que ce sera
un débat des baisses de taux des hausses
de taux ou une pause qui continue mais
là pour l'instant le marché de l'emploi
demeure solide le marché de l'emploi
demeure sous tension il y a beaucoup de
postes vacants il se crée encore de
l'emploi au Canada ce créé encore de
l'emploi mais ça fait que le e trimestre
de trois mois seulement où les marges
bénéficiaires sont en retrait et au
Canada et aux États-Unis
parce qu'on commence à annoncer des
suppressions d'emplois la façon dont ça
fonctionne vous avez mentionné tout à
l'heure le PIB la croissance PIB elle
était nul au quatrième trimestre lorsque
normalement le PIB ralenti après ça il y
a un impact sur l'embauche et après ça
l'impact sur l'inflation continue donc
moi je pense que les prochains mois pour
être moins porteur pour la création
d'emploi moins important ou donc
suppression d'emploi disons les mots on
le voit déjà dans certaines industries
oui dans le secteur des technologies de
l'information en particulier donc
récession au Canada à peu près la
plupart des économistes s'entendent pour
dire que ça va être une récession mais
de quel ampleur bah c'est ça puis tu
sens la nuée de nuance à faire à ce
niveau là parce que n'oubliez pas que
pour les entreprises ce qui est inédit
dans ce cycle ici c'est qu'il y a une
possibilité de réduire les effectifs en
y allant avec l'attrition parce que plus
de gens qui quittent leur emploi pour
cause de retraite que de population qui
rentre sur le marché du travail dans
plusieurs pays sur le CDI même le Canada
en donc dans ce contexte là
c'est stagnation économique oui le mot
récession dépression apocalypse ça je
pense que les gens vont trop loin
apocalypse soit on entend du sort
récemment ici
prévisionniste qui parlait de cela pour
dire que le pire était à venir et dans
le marché et dans l'économie et qu'on
avait rien vu vous êtes où par rapport à
ça je vais vous dire il faut faire des
nuances là-dessus ok l'Apocalypse là
pour le marché financiers c'est
lorsqu'on tombe en mode déflation est-ce
que quelqu'un qui parle de déflation en
ce moment je vous donne un autre exemple
dans les années 70 il y avait un peu
plus d'inflation il y avait une guerre
du Vietnam 53000 morts 300.000 blessés
l'économie est en croissance les marchés
baissaient oui d'accord contraction au
niveau des multiples mais il y avait la
croissance économique même dans un
contexte là la pire chose pour les
marchés mais financiers c'est
effectivement c'est le mode déflation
qu'on a connu en 2008-2009 qui a
nécessité des mesures très musclées des
banques centrales la chose Monsieur
Fillon par contre le faux s'habituer que
c'est fini l'époque des taux à zéro avec
des banques centrales je pense qu'on est
dans une transition qui nous amène vers
autre chose et qui dit des gros mots
peut imaginer que ça ressemble à une
dépression économique et ça c'est
complètement exagéré mais tu exagéré
dans un contexte en général c'est il
faut que ça vienne au niveau de la
déflation or la transition énergétique
qui s'annonce au Canada et dans
plusieurs pays du monde elle est plutôt
inflationniste que l'inflationniste donc
c'est pour ça que le mot apocalypse
c'est mal choisi dans ce contexte
dernier mot sur le dollar canadien notre
dollar faibli quand même il va continuer
de faiblir jusqu'où on laisse tomber le
dollar canadien
on est rendu à 72 là
c'est que vous supposez qu'il y aura
aucun ordre de hausse des taux aux
États-Unis sur l'économie américaine moi
je m'attends quand un deuxième moitié
d'année le ralentissement au niveau de
l'économie américaine soit très évident
et qui amène à réserve à prendre une
pause ou est-ce que au revers ça
pourrait obliger la Banque du Canada
augmenter ses taux d'intérêt pour que
l'écart ne grandisse pas trop avec les
États-Unis non faut gérer notre nos
économies en fonction de nos
vulnérabilités respectives or au Canada
c'est 33% des hypothèques qui sont à
taux variables aux États-Unis c'est 5%.
donc vous comprendrez que dans ce
contexte là chaque hausse de taux au
Canada l'impact est décuplé par rapport
à ce qu'on voit aux États-Unis vous êtes
très intéressant comme d'habitude merci
Stéphane merci au revoir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI